- And the poll just came out
and I'm tied with Jeb Bush and I said,
"Oh that's too bad.
"How can I be tied with this guy?
"He's terrible, he's terrible."
(cheering and laughing)
- [Voiceover] You've
heard him on television.
You've seen him on the internet.
He's so many places,
how can you keep track?
You couldn't until now.
Introducing "Donald Trump's Greatest Hits:
"June 2015 to August 2015".
All the Donald you need in one small
16 disc DVD compilation featuring
work from such classic
rants as "Immigration".
- I will build a great, great
wall on our southern border
and I will have Mexico pay for that wall.
- [Voiceover] "War Heroes".
- He's a war hero cause he was captured.
I like people that weren't captured, okay.
I hate to tell you that.
- [Voiceover] And "Political Rivals".
- Your senator, what a stiff.
What a stiff, Lindsey Graham.
(laughing)
- [Voiceover] Not to mention
a bevy of his top chart hits.
- Our leaders are stupid.
Our politicians are stupid.
I'm really rich, I assure you that.
(laughing)
I beat China all the time.
What's this guy, a beggar?
- [Voiceover] Somebody's
doing the raping, Don.
I mean who's doing the raping?
- [Voiceover] Act now and
you'll receive the bonus
"You're a Loser" disc absolutely free.
- They're losers. They're just losers.
- [Voiceover] But there's more.
We'll even throw in exclusive clips
from his first and only debate.
- You've called women you don't like
fat pigs, dogs, slobs,
and disgusting animals.
Your Twitter account has several --
- Only Rosie O'Donnell.
(laughing)
- [Voiceover] He's
prolific, he's bombastic,
and he could be yours America,
and by that I mean your president.
Seriously, he's polling very well.
(upbeat rock music)